good evening and good morning depending
on where you are and i want to welcome
all of you to the panel discussion
uh how must corporate training programs
change in a post-pandemic business world
we have
a
nice expert panel today and before we
get started before i introduce them i'm
going to
remind folks of the webex controls to
ask questions of our panelists please
use the q a box
um direct your question to all panelists
same thing with the chat if you do want
to put a
comment in the chat
address all panelists that way
uh everyone will see it on the panel
rather than just me
my name is stuart creek i'm a marketing
manager here at simplylearn
i'm going to start with a little poll
about yourselves before we introduce our
panel
so
allow me to
open this poll
if you are watching on live stream
you can put your responses into
the comments
for the rest of you you should see the
polling widget
just curious to know your role and also
we've been asking
regularly how people are doing
in the pandemic so
here is the result of the poll
and about a third of you are in learning
and development
with it
marketing and sales operations
so
uh
skewed toward learning and development
which is what we expected and
it's good to see that um
most of our audience is feeling well
today um
so we hope that this panel discussion
will
give you some valuable information that
you can use
in your
own enterprise
with that i'm going to introduce our
panelists
marbusker uh is a vp
global business services it for
flex
is a global
contract manufacturing and engineering
firm that designs and produces products
for other companies
and it's
a
large global enterprise at this time
um
barnabatcharya is a talent learning
partner for abb in the india and south
asia south east asia region
um
abb being the
large
multinational
engineering firm
and we're very pleased to have both of
you here today
um
welcome
and thank you thank you
glad to be here
thank you um
just uh a brief agenda i'm gonna be this
is a conversation between
um our panelists and this is uh how
pandemic has affected corporate training
um how it's highlighted the need for
lifelong learning
which new skills enterprises will need
in this post-pandemic era
how enterprises
have to adapt to new business conditions
and new
training requirements
and advantages of role-based learning
programs tailored to your company
both flex and abb are clients
simply learn so
they can speak to
how that works for them
we will have a q a with members of the
audience
and
with that i'm going to stop sharing this
presentation
and we'll move on to our conversation
so uh
the first question is
again how's the pandemic affected
corporate training uh
parnak
you say that
it's become more frequent more intense
is there is there a difference in tempo
yeah yeah actually that you're right so
what i observed you know i just uh in
2020
march when we were just uh we were asked
to work from home and all and
the regular way of learning was
interrupted and for a point i thought
you know how what will be the landscape
of learning what will be the future of
learning you know what will be the
frequency how will be the mold and it
was pretty
i was not aware but what happened you
know stewart is that i could actually
see how beautifully the whole landscape
took a very different space you know
that's the time when i saw that all
these platforms like where i would like
open open learning you know simulation
simulated platforms or you know this uh
online learning platforms they created
the habit i think they gave you know
licenses free licenses for 30 days for
40 days and you know a bunch of life so
that
in other organizations they understand
that you know that there's a 24x7
learning possible anytime you know so
that culture which we have adopted has
become quite intense yeah
yes
and
we've
all experienced to work from home um
a big shift in our what we used to call
a circadian rhythm
when we had uh you know
daytime and nighttime but now it's more
24-hour kind of cycle where we work at
different intervals we learn at
different intervals and
uh
have you seen the
qualitative nature in the kind of skills
that people
require
or that you require your people to have
yeah yeah thanks for asking um
i
see one one thing which farmer said
right for sure all of a sudden there
were just too many options like too many
trainings and too many free webinars
every product vendor also gave free
training so what was
previously paid uh trainings right so a
lot of trainings when the my team
members actually selected themselves
they were interested i i saw that shift
so the quality of learning helped
uh not just a manager saying go and
attend this training
but i think there was a push and pull as
well right both sides where they
actually needed that training they were
interested and they spent more time so i
i thought the quality definitely went up
right the learning quality went up in
the beginning right i think that was a
burnout after some time but in the
beginning i think there was really
really good traction
yeah uh
again with the
with the shift in our schedules we found
that we had time
to devote to the things that we may have
been putting off
including
our self-directed learning uh which is
an interesting aspect how how do you
think that the self-directed learning
because it
has
integrated itself with corporate
directed learning
you want to address someone
yeah so
so if i really understand your question
because your voice is breaking so it's
little bit better
yeah
go ahead uh so the question was
how does self-directed learning
uh integrate now with corporate learning
i apologize for the audio let me see if
i can fix this
yeah
some words are getting kind of eaten up
by this are you are you able to hear me
now yeah this is better
i apologize for that um so i was asking
about corporate learning versus
self-directed learning how has
how have the two merged
yeah so uh i think uh the best uh the
way it happened is that
um
people realized that there is this uh
continuous need
to upgrade you know so that that that
was definitely a big understanding that
they understood and
then there did this embrace
embrace of uh you know any kind of any
kind of uh
direction
let it be it corporate trainings or you
know any kind of a self kind of
trainings i think they've merged at a
particular point right and more and more
i see today is that you know this this
this mindset of continuous learning is
coming up you know and i have seen
instead of it before before pandemic
what we saw that we used to push
trainings to them but today it is not
that it's like they know okay this is
something i need to learn they contract
with themselves that okay this is
something in the next five months or six
months i am in a current competency
level here within three to four months i
want to reach there you know that
contracting and then creating the
learning habits and all that it's it's
pretty interesting to see how
people are looking at themselves and
then there are reasons for that also
industry if you allow me i can just let
you know you know
yeah so the reasons uh why i see that uh
employees corporates and you know people
who are in profession wants to remain
relevant is that you know if you see
externally the kind of trends that we
see
that there is a digitization is going to
create to summer something or 250
million jobs globally you know that's
that that that the trend that we see
then there will be you know kind of
automation which is coming so heavily
you know and it's going to partially
kind of replace around 50 percent of
jobs in u.s that's these are like data
or stats that mckinsey
talks about right
and also these uh retirement which is a
very good thing that you know that that
retirement age of 60 or something that
is blurring you know there
a time is going to come when uh when
when your skill will be more important
than your age and if you are making
you're still relevant with it i think
there is no retirement age so the need
for learning and upgrading is going up
okay
and uh
obviously this kind of a low carbon
economy transition from uh that we are
doing to low carbon economy and it's
going to kind of uh
there are some ships in the job sector
that we need to do which require
different kind of absolute different
skills
and these pointers i think people are
realizing and that's why they're taking
up learning so seriously be it corporate
with self with any kind you know that
that's the trend i see
thank you
go ahead
yeah yeah sorry so it's actually it's a
great question right i think in the
beginning i think there was all this
interest people went to all kinds of
trainings as particularly data science
and aiml all these fancy
trainings that almost everyone went for
that and we don't have so many jobs for
data scientists right so at some point
we had to yeah inter intervene and
actually we stopped some of these free
trainings like
the webinars and we actually started
qualifying hey do you need it or not or
can you do it later because otherwise a
lot of time was going in these trainings
which were not directly relevant to
their jobs right so that dialogue
started happening after six months into
the pandemic right and then we started
saying okay this is relevant you take
this you take it later and then we
started channelizing that right we had
to yeah yeah that makes sense i mean
and that leads into an another question
which is
you know what new skills do
enterprises need in this post-pandemic
year have you seen a
shift in the skill sets that you want
your people to have
for sure for sure so it's in in our case
clearly
the ability to understand data right
think on the feet i think this pandemic
has pushed us to
to really difficult uh you know
conditions right and uh working remotely
and and data becomes even more important
right i think a big shift in using data
analytics uh as has happened and uh so
so people need to be a little more
objective i think working together right
uh had that convenience uh that 2k could
get into a room or get into a
conversation and resolve things but now
it's more objective more data and on
calls too many calls right so it is more
to the point uh definitely the skill set
i'm looking for in people is
ability to analyze and speak data right
and of course in senior people at i
think this happened even before the
pandemic i think the world was
requiring more people with more
curiosity right learning new skills it's
a vuca world right things are changing
people need to upgrade anyway right
curiosity was one and and of course the
ability to connect the dots right uh
when once you can see data can you
connect the dots that if we stop payment
to to to a supplier will we get shipment
the next time right for us supply chain
is so important right so i think that
ability people need to start thinking
right not just doing is important i
think
okay
partner with your review
yes i i think uh what what uh sukumar
said it's perfectly ba you know kind of
bang on and but there are certain also
skills which are required to function in
this world
which is so new say for example these
are the skill of emotionally uh you know
emotional intelligence you know this
intelligence i think is a is of supreme
need
for
every individual today to understand you
know kind of i have a res you know how
do we in this in this remote world when
you many things are misjudged when you
think your communication is you don't
know
there was a time when you know you're
you're used to a certain kind of
communication you know face to face
where you smile or you show your
frustrations and all that in a different
way today uh most of the time we are not
even on videos or how do you get the
cues from the voice or from a certain
word the person is using i think that's
a huge kind of how do you how do you
have those skills get those skills it's
a tremendous amount of
skill that is required to function
and operate in the correct manner in a
in an agile manner otherwise there will
be a lot of conflicts
not um
you know deliver
so um
yeah so that is that is definitely one
part
the rest is
digitization
yeah can you hear me yes
yeah
so definite other skills are like you
know skills like sustainability those
kind of skills here you know um say say
skills on digital skills that technology
technology contending skills that is
definitely going to be forefronted
because we will be using more remote
kind of uh apps and we will be you know
into a different
world um which will accept tomorrow that
okay that's the world that we live in
so i think these things are what are the
trends that i i see which are
ghost goes without saying a digital
digital transformation it started even
before the pandemic is just accelerated
right and it's just
yes great point yes yes
yeah i mean we
we were
just getting used to the idea of having
our restaurants delivered to us through
doordash and
ordering everything online and then
suddenly
these
uh conveniences became necessities so
that's because
that
changed business conditions globally
it's changed how people can do uh
learning and development programs if you
can't get people into
the classroom together physically you
have to do it
some other ways so
um
partner and then supermarket how do you
set up new training programs
how do you
get the program in place and drive it up
to the workforce
yeah
yeah so great question again so
initially i was as i said that i was
thinking that how that will happen how
how the face-to-face trainings how those
chemistry that we have in our session in
a classroom session can be replaced
remotely things all those things came up
but i uh you know how the
uh everything you know if it's it's a
need based like there is a tremendous
amount of needs uh need to learn and
group because everything was changing so
learning became unknowingly was the
heart of the functioning of during the
pandemic you know when we shifted so uh
one thing that i uh i observed in abb
that we did is that
change in the culture say for example
bringing in technology say for example
mural so when we were doing uh
brainstorming sessions or we are we are
bringing people for designing thinking
sessions we used mural like they're
beautiful platforms though they were
though i i absolutely saw how this
platform grew chemistry ms team from
what it was to what it is today it all
has it's only facilitated our way of
connects and
so obviously picking up those uh those
those platforms as you know and and and
knowing it
being more strong in the way you use the
tools and the functions and you know
still keep like say for example
you know how do you really keep the
energy and keep the chemistry on as you
speak
this
this this itself is a new new new kind
of a tool in a new kind of learning
right looking at the camera
your shoulders you just have your face
and shoulders and hands but i think
all of these have really really made a
lot of change we
we survived and we survived we did more
i think we did 3x training we are now
very easy to connect people are more
easily accessible so overall if you say
the learning landscape is pretty vibrant
and exuberant and a lot of energy here
that's fine
yeah so if i have to add i add to that
right i think classroom training there's
more we have seen there's more attention
and we could actually see people
responding are they focusing completely
online with videos of like how my kids
are taking classes right they're they're
looking at something else right they're
really not following the class and so on
so that could happen in an online
training so so what we changed over time
right so we saw that it was happening
people log in and they just don't don't
respond don't ask questions nothing so
we insisted that they turn their videos
on right number one and we made it very
interactive right it has to be a
dialogue the training itself was more of
discussion oriented and not classroom
showing the presentation and so no not
just that combination we have breakout
rooms and zoom so we form teams on on on
zoom and they'll go and come back with
their inputs
i think that has changed over the last
one year right how to conduct an online
training it can't be a one-way
trading it has to be interactive with
lot of polls and then even a test at the
end right they have to take so yeah
that's that's some change we had to
undergo
yeah i mean that's an excellent point is
that
in the classroom environment
the physical classroom environment
it's
easy to see if somebody's engaged it's
easy to
point to them and direct their
engagement
and you have to start
as you've discovered you have to
create analogs for that on the virtual
environment so that
you can't keep people engaged you can't
make sure that
they're interacting with the material
and the instructor and with their peers
can you is it happening with you as well
it's it's breaking a bit yeah here now
and then yes
i have a chronic problem with the setup
i have here uh and i apologize for that
but i'm talking about the the fact that
you pointed out that you have to
create
virtual analogs for the physical things
that happen in the classroom as both of
you were saying
where you can see the student where you
can engage with the student directly and
as you as you found out
you need to do the same thing in the
virtual environment and make sure that
you can
get people to answer questions make sure
they're there
they're paying attention so
um
what do you feel about the effectiveness
of virtual training um
do you think that it's
well adopted by your by your uh teams
and
that they're responsive to it and
getting the skills transfer that you
want
yeah but for now you're going to start
off yeah i could start so i what i see
basically what i will i the way i look
at it
um
the content and uh you know the way data
the information comes the content come
all of this you know
it is effective but the idea is how do
how do it is now you know the onus you
know that is the culture shift as i all
the time say that it is no longer before
it was like what is the roi what is this
what is that it was the onus on the
learning or things like that but today
it is not
the shift is that you have to be a
continuous learner a lifelong learner
show the effectiveness be a multiplier
you know celebrate your learnings you
know this is what i'm trying to say an
organization who's adopting a culture
like this will not spend time in sitting
and calculating the effectiveness of
learning
that is
what many smart organizations have
understood that instead of sitting and
uh okay this how many hours and how many
learning hours happened all of that
instead of that how many people are
coming out and sharing their learning
how many people are there are making
people better you know how many people
are making bite size videos and
ascending within the creating community
communications insights so i think that
shift many a lot of organization have
started big uh you know in fact role
models who have started speaking about
those things you know so i think
it is getting effective because it's a
very new culture that is hitting in a
lot of people because i am spearheading
this culture in abb and i see there is a
set of people who are really motivated
engaged who are really adopting it fast
and i have never seen those set of you
know that kind of a talent who are now
becoming a turn talent turn down means
like if i am suppose i am doing learning
talent today you know i i grew myself in
such a manner that tomorrow i become a
kind of a marketing strategy you know i
can turn my entire career so that is
what i will have to say uh to use to it
okay that's that's
that's that's a great point
to totally agree
okay
um
to
just raise the question though
when you talk about
i mean you just met
you don't
put as much emphasis on formal metrics
as the internal ones yes
yes
so um
i i can speak for flex as well right so
yeah so we we used to track definitely
number of hours and and then talk to the
managers after three months of training
and what was the effectiveness and have
they picked up skills are they showing
it could be technical or soft skills
right
but i
agree with warner that it's slowly
changing yeah there is a certification
for a technical thing which is really
good right it helps us but it's also
engagement right it is also that they
have access to these trainings and they
have made it little more voluntary right
so since that element is there i think
them coming forward itself is because
they're interested so i think there is a
quality uh which is which is which is uh
getting added uh as well as yeah it's an
engagement people are happier right
because they have access to more
trainings
before the pandemic that's for sure
right yeah so
that's an interesting insight from both
of you which is that it's not a matter
of
you know ticking the boxes of how many
people have gotten their certificates
it's you know how how effective
are they in
you know
taking the information to heart and
applying it in their work so
um
carter you mentioned lifelong learning
as an
important factor
and
uh
people
employees have both their professional
lives and their personal
interests
and do you
kind of see a
synergy when somebody is
when you're trying to
get them to
adopt lifelong learning for
their job skills
um you see that
there's a correlation between
the people who
have a lifelong learning attitude
towards
their personal lives or their personal
hobbies and things like that
so kumar can you did you unders i mean
actually stuart again there was a lot of
uh disturbances actually
the last
part even i i i missed what so i think
it's around lifelong life-long learning
but when you connect with a fictional i
missed that one well what i was saying
is that
that
there's lifelong learning with respect
to
job skills
there's also lifelong learning for
example if somebody is
a woodworker in their spare time
and
they continue to learn new techniques
and
try new things do you see that there's a
correlation or an overlap
yeah so i think yeah there is a
correlation
so correct me if i i've understood the
question so that says that so in the
life of learning it is not only the
skills at professional skills but also
you're saying that maybe it uh it is
also the hobbies and all that you know
other things as well right yeah
absolutely absolutely you know it's a
very very interesting question i i
really really uh you know would like to
answer this and this i've seen in my uh
you know i have seen
uh that there was this lady who was uh
actually doing um was
she took up this
continuous learning thing that she will
know the products of abb really well so
that she will uh present it in front of
the customers and so she picked it up so
so that is
what she was learning from the
perspective of her work but at the same
time that habit of the way she picked up
that life learning she picked up other
languages believe me she picked up uh
you know
spanish she picked up german and what
happened her knowledge now she can
multiply it with the other hobbies that
she could not do when she was and now
today all these two things got coupled
and finally the organization is getting
a lot of benefit out of it so yeah i
mean this is this is real this is a real
story
i totally agree and and yeah this is a
direct correlation like learning
languages and
and being applicable to the work but in
my case i
i definitely encourage and myself to
write i'm learning guitar since the
pandemic broke right i'm actually doing
online classes and so on so i think it
is the learning culture as you say it
becomes a habit right and and that
what we learn in personal helps us in
professional i believe that and what we
learn professionally also helps us in a
person right so we keep learning new
skills either way to survive and uh and
thrive as well right yeah for sure
and and what
what techniques do you use to encourage
people
to adopt that lifelong learning mindset
yeah that's a i will ask i will answer
because i'm into this actually
so we created so you know i it's um i
will share a little bit about me because
this i did
with you know and i i mean to create
this whole concept and culture of
continuous learning i did a lot of
research and became a continuous learner
and that's when i realized you know this
entire people are talking so much about
this continuous learning process but
you will not find a kind of a process
really anywhere you know these are bits
and doors somebody's telling atomic
habits are great somebody has saying
that you have to know the learning style
so all of these are all scattered and
why once i did this whole research i
actually you know could create a kind of
a
a process around it say for example this
part of contracting it starts with you
it doesn't start with your manager or
anybody starts with you and then you can
always keep a buddy or an ally you know
continuous learning ally who will keep
you in uh your contract in in in in line
so that's the first then you create an
environment say for example what is the
best time what is the best environment
how much distraction you can allow you
know so that that's comes second third
is that what i'd like even if you are
like it's not about three hours four
hours of learning it's just about that
little habit that you create and you
really stick to it and it doesn't pinch
you even in a difficulty so that's there
that habits and then comes resources
that is the most challenging thing you
know that is so much as sukumar also
talked about today you want to learn
more guitars you will get 1000 videos
and you really have to pick up uh the
one that
so how you how you plan do the resource
planning itself is a is a good thing to
do and then finally the celebration of
sharing and caring and becoming a
multiplier you know holding sessions
doing videos
i think this is a wonderful way to bring
that culture shift and
bringing being being in that's that's
what
uh
i find making sense
um
you've mentioned a couple of times
uh partner the idea
of seeing somebody
making a mini video or
[Music]
someone else and
that brings up um
you know a common theme that
you know martial arts and things like
that is you don't
really have mastery of something until
you've taught it to someone
else so
is that something that that
you're
more aware of now in this in this
environment that
you want to see people not just
get certified new skill but show that
they are able to
help others
um and share what they've learned and
try to multiply that within the
organization
yeah uh yeah that's uh that's why i am
just talking about this it's like
whatever you learn if that can be shared
you know what happens is that as an
employee that's the glue to the
organization and you are
also watched apart like you people will
will be you become focused today see
what happened we are all faceless
because most of the time we are not face
to face and
right
and you've just frozen for a moment but
i'm sure it'll be back um can you
comment a little on that while we're
waiting for partnership conducting a
culture like this and uh
yeah right
you believe you also think that and
another thing happens is that there are
a lot of
uh profiles coming up now if your people
inside are
they say that okay i know this i have a
continuous learner and i'm in this stage
in this level of competence imagine the
amount of savings the organization has
or how easy it is for
the organization as well
with this kind of habit of sharing and
caring and picking you know getting what
you really want so this whole thing of
uh
the secret like you get nothing is
impossible you get you attract what you
want can happen only by sharing what you
do yeah
great great point and and and in flex uh
we have done this since when we have
made this transition also in the last uh
two years
always we had trained the trainer right
see technology just my team right we
have india iit team we have 60 plus
technology skills there are so many
different skills and each of them cannot
go for all of them cannot go for all the
training so see we want we pick one or
two people they get trained from the
vendor and then they do train the
trainer that's always been there but in
the last one and half years we have
started making bite-sized training
modules like e-learning so we have an
e-learning team and this is more
on-the-job training right so we have
vendors like simply learn
where they give a generic technical
training but then on the job for flex
what integrations they need to do and
how to implement something we have
created many videos right at least 100
e-learning videos three minutes
bite-sized trainings and and that's
sharing right and that that is good for
both sides you hear from the experts the
seniors as well as the people who of
course know they learn and all the
people who are teaching are also very
happy
that's a
wonderful wonderful insight
and it helps create the
shared culture
of
expectation of learning but also
expectation of sharing so
that's really powerful
uh technique both of you are
applying um
we talk about roles based learning
programs that do you
look at
your skills gaps based on
individual roles and say
here's a
place where we're
lacking a particular
skill set or we see the industry is
going in a direction that we need to
retrain
all of um
how do you
pursue that type of directed learning
sure maybe i could start so again in in
it
all the time we're moving to new
technologies right so uh in the
analytics space we are moving from a
system called teradata to snowflake then
we have we need we have a training
training plan
no fault by role business analyst or a
developer employer right but that's more
mass training but we also the last two
years we have started maturing with the
individual development plan i think
every company talks about it but not a
lot of attention is paid to right we
have a performance appraisal but very
closely we have to create this
individual development plan identify the
trainings what is suitable or needed for
that role and
analyze the gaps uh i think there is
more ownership now from the employees as
well and it needs to come from that as
well right the first ownership and then
the manager it's a partnership but the
ownership lies with the employee itself
and
and now it's we have started to document
it and and we have a tracking mechanism
is that progress right every three
months so we are slowly maturing i would
not say we're completely mature with
that but yeah we are pushing that quite
hard
okay
um foreign
so yeah more or less in that manner you
know that uh so
what happens is that we are we have
employing some kind of a artificial
intelligence
platform right where
we look at each and every people like
the people underwriting or the talent
underwriting the way we look at finance
underwriting like to like to do that
strategy you know to have you know
execute that strategy in the next 18 to
22 months time what kind of talent do
you have today and if you have that what
is the gap and how do you bridge it so
in our people discussions it becomes you
know very interestingly these points are
captured and that's when
you know this this this gaps like can be
like are synthesized like okay so this
is the person here
this role has been given or a bigger
responsibility so okay what is the gap
right and the system is captured and
then finally it's in like it keeps uh
directions like these are the kind of
sessions that can these people get and
then we merge it with our learning
ecosystem and then it gets
you know
addressed it yeah
this brings up an interesting idea um
in the in the environment we're in now
uh
how do you handle onboarding
game employees
and
getting them trained and
acculturated to the company
and
to their new roles
when
you can't be face to face with them
in the kind of environment that
that we uh traditionally expected
absolutely
did you catch my question yeah i yeah i
did okay
go ahead
okay yeah no that's that's a challenge i
think that the biggest challenge is with
new employees joining like during
pandemic we have not met them in person
and those coffee no welcomes and intros
which we could have it's missing and and
the learning which happens when they are
in the office just swivel your chair and
ask a question from a senior and so on
right so so we have more formal
induction programs right for sure so so
one is induction into the company and
then
trainings
previously when they were in the office
when newcomers especially the fresh
graduates it used to be a six weeks boot
camp six weeks now we've made it to two
weeks actually two weeks and also
definitely the eight hour training
programs are now three to five hours a
day right probably people cannot take
more than that on zoom so we've reduced
it but then we have definitely more
pointed training so we have avoiding
general overviews and getting to know
people and so on but more pointed
specific trainings much lesser time and
then there's a lot of on-the-job
training honestly this it is a challenge
for people coming in new
right lot more attention from the
managers required and they're hesitant
to ask a question as well right they're
new they don't know if they can ask a
question on zoom and chat and so on so a
lot more calls are happening but i feel
that delay in onboarding is there right
because of this
and it takes more time
yeah i i actually agree with what uh
sukumar said that's true we you know you
can do so much
but that that's where the manager if the
manager is not a person who can who has
this mindset of making people better
then
there can be a problem yeah
very well
um
this is a great time i think for us to
transition to the q a with the audience
um we had
several questions that came in and i'd
like to
pose those to you before we
move on to uh
completing the the program
um
so
we have a
a visitor
on our linkedin channel uh
like i am not gonna
say this name correctly
he asks if there's an impact on training
efficacy those pandemic
operations
seeing that training is uh falling off
efficiency or
are you having to
how are you having to modify training
programs
in this
academic world to make sure that
you get
the operational employee up to speed
but
address that first
okay yeah no we just talked about that
right i think the operational onboarding
is taking more time for sure uh it it
it is done right but what used to take
four weeks or five weeks to fully
onboard a person it taking little few
more weeks like it's probably being
eight weeks to 10 weeks so but
outside of onboarding also i mean when
you when you talk about for example
needing to switch over to a different
platform and
find that
retraining
of existing employees
is going slower but it's less efficient
or do you find that the online
environment is actually helping you
online i would say online environment is
helping i i have challenges only in the
onboarding of new people but existing
employees they just love this and take
the training at my convenience so at the
time assigned and uh
and also there are recordings something
new which has happened in this pandemic
is every session is recorded in zoom and
we share the recording session so even
if they can't attend they can always go
and go back to it right so it has become
more efficient
for the existing employees new trainings
would you agree with that
yeah i absolutely agree absolutely
that's that's what even
what
sukumar said is what i agree and echo
okay
um
we have
a question that was directed for you
parna uh from petro who asks
are there best practices
in designing blended learning
did you catch that
i could hear best practices and then
yeah
he asked about best practices
uh designing blended learning programs
best
uh best practice in designing uh
designing what
learning
blended learning
okay
so see there is no best practice in
terms if i have to class that it is not
about
any best practice so
how if the way i do i can share about it
i don't know about the others so
what the way i do it is that target for
whom i am going to create that learning
path or line learning design it's very
important to have
to do a kind of a rosebud thorn with
them so what's what they're angry about
what they want to learn about like start
stop continue kind of uh situations and
understand their ecosystem like from
where they are working then look at the
material that you are going to push okay
and then you have to you know you have
to split it in a manner that there will
be certain
certain pieces which are really
contextually high where you need to have
a you know more of a face to face
connects versus some background and
context that the person can read out so
so the whole thing needs to be
storyboarded so blended learning is just
not that something email something
there's some case studies not it's a
it's absolutely a storyboarding that you
do and then you run it through
any you know a learner who is like who
will go through it and get onto a
critiquing mode with that person only
then go ahead and replicate it say you
know send it out that's very important
either the learner or the learner's
marriage manager this two set of people
needs to go through this critiquing
process of the blending method
before you roll it out and say that hey
you know this is it because it is
actually a kind of a it's a customized
and you have to know the customer
journey through it this is actually
taking a customer as a journey through
it so you have to know the pin points
you have to know the pleasure points of
it so that's my take of the way i do it
thank you
um
i've had a question from blue passion
linkedin who asks
and i think my interpretation of the
question is
if you are dealing with
physical skills
uh
how do you
adapt that in this environment um
or is this kind of a moot question
because if somebody has to do the
physical skills by definition they have
to be
in a physical environment where they can
be trained directly
or are there
ways to do this type of
training virtually
for people who are doing manual or
physical skills
yeah so sukumar if you want to take it
first and then i can add it like i mean
you just let me know yeah no even in our
factories right so so now we use
augmented reality for doing trainings
right across sites so because travel we
can't travel uh due to pandemic so we we
are using this uh you know even for
physical uh fixing of no
chips and boards and so on we do that it
has started and me myself i told i
learned guitar online right so i think
that's a that's a physical skill as well
it's it's possible
it's not the same but it's it's a
combination of auditory visual and some
hands-on right learning happens somehow
right it's not ideal but yeah learning
happens that's what i'm saying yes
absolutely so i think you're you're very
true superman like that we have this
augmented or virtual uh
mode of uh you know where you uh
simulations those are wonderful ways to
bring the bring up this physical skills
and and and it's been used like
end-to-end like too much it is being
used today even sometimes you know like
us customer calls or customer demos
which are at time when you do a product
demo like
such a you know some engineering
products which really needs to be those
are also being taken care of with little
bit of an augmented
intelligent
technology that i have to say
we have ramesh who asks an interesting
question about
the variables of attitude of skills of
knowledge
um
question and i'm not sure how to
interpret it but i'll just say it
how does one structure education versus
vocational skill sets does that make
sense
uh can i see this
see that question somewhere
yeah i'll put that in the um
here man
yeah
working in the remote session is quite
isolating no okay the other attitude
skills knowledge being variables how do
how do one structure education versus
vocational skill sets
okay
so as i said that you it is it starts
with you you know you have to you are
the person who knows what you want to
learn
how you want to learn what attitude from
what space you want to learn okay so
that's this i think that contracting for
learning
be is beat you know beat education or
vocation and whatever what kind of
whatever you want to pick up that
contracting is extremely important where
your attitude and and your uh where you
are in terms of the competency for that
particular that gets aligned you it's a
you can go ahead with
any kind of training you you know and
you you automatically will create your
structures and habits and repetitions
and and and and experimentations
all of that your growth mindset will
come if you are going to do that so
that's my
that's my
my answer to that sukumar if you want to
add something no don't you think that
makes sense
it makes sense it makes sense
okay
um i think
we have time for this last question um
which is
from alicia
who asks
working in remote remotely is very
isolating so
how do you
keep morale
of the teammates yeah yeah so that
frankly i think alisha by this time you
will have your answers i mean it's uh
because you can we we repeatedly so
sukumar and all of us we kind of talked
about this habit of picking up
continuous learning so today the mind
has changed it's not about your team
member your team leader will not push
your supervisor will not push you it's
you who will contract your own self you
will we will pick up your engagement and
maybe your manager you can keep that
manager as your uh as your ally or a
person accountability partner you know
so the so so so the you know the tables
have turned it's it's not today
anybody's going to push you it's you
who's going to move forward and when you
do that there is no question of
motivation because it's an inner force
that you're doing it and you will be
motivated and motivation is always inner
it cannot be it cannot be pumped from
outside that's the truth that's the
that's something that you have to have
yeah absolutely absolutely and and as as
a manager i think
we we want to connect with people like
don't i think we should not ignore the
people who are not you know are
timid and they're not speaking out i
think that has increased in the last one
and of years is yeah ensure that we
connect with people so that they don't
feel this isolation or i'm not getting
uh the the trainings and so on and so
from a manager perspective as long as we
can facilitate and give information
communicate about the trainings and
engagement activities it's up to the
individual totally to to leverage that
right totally okay
there's a
there was a management trend called
management by walking around
and
in today's environment
you really can't walk around
like you said you can't
turn to your colleague in the next
cubicle or you can't walk over to your
employees uh
office and check in with them
um
i'm taking one last look here from a
question
paul scott
on the youtube channel
asked a question related to what we just
spoke about
um how is
remote learning
being used to foster engagement between
employees how do you
is this a tool that you're using to get
your team members to engage with one
another in uh
remote learning remote learning itself
yeah the remote learning environment is
that helping people yeah
it's interesting we just started a
initiative like completely new
we called it learn out loud
it's like a combined study which we used
to do in our schools and colleges so
learn out loud we we pick a topic so
last time we picked a topic on respect
and value right how important it is in
the company and we invited all the
senior
one level above so 150 people joined and
we just had a discussion right we we let
people unmute and speak and if they have
anything to share i it was very very
well appreciated and it was it was
learning from each other right so yes we
have we are trying something
yeah and then there are these platforms
there's a lot of this gamified platforms
you know where you can design your
program say for example we also have
a part of our induction which is on
gamified where people get badges and
then they get they they have this uh
leaderboard and all that they see and
then they go ahead and finish their
those sessions there so that is a
wonderful platform which we are also
leveraging for
online mentoring you know where people
enter it's like a facebook account they
enter and they create a mentor can
create their mentoring account menti can
create a mentee account and then it will
like you know kind of a tinder can get
matched up and then you find your mentor
and mentor online and then so those kind
of those are definitely um
the new age way of learning where you
meet people where you do things in this
kind of a platform which is a
transparent platform and you yeah
and you are also learning from the peers
so there are a lot of peer cohorts where
you go and it's it's fantastic like you
can you can there is no end to how you
can use this
platforms to get the get so many
analytics also at the end that's the
best part that you really can draw
analytics and you know kind of do a
present presentation at the end and
understand what went right wrong enough
so yeah
this has been a wonderful session thank
you very much
uh
i'm going to go ahead and
move on to the closing but i wanted to
thank both of you
and
um
i'm going to do one more
quick pull of the audience
and
and this is basically to ask
our audience members what skill sets
they're looking
uh with technical skills so they're
looking to add into their teams or
improving their teams
and when they're looking to do it
about 20 more seconds on the pole
close it in about 10 seconds
uh
business project management is uh the
most popular of the categories
and then a kind of a distribution across
ai
to full sac digital marketing
it's encouraging to see that
most of your planning
to
proceed right away
as somebody once said
now is the best time to do something and
so with that
move on and thank
our guests our panelists today
sure
thank you thank you very much stuart and
parna this was a pleasure and i learned
a lot thank you
thank you thank you so much yeah same
here it's a continuous learning
great
uh
we do want to mention a webinar series
we do
webinars for the
more general audience uh
basically three
four categories master classes with
subject matter experts
uh we have thought leadership webinars
we have
career strategy webinars and we do have
previews of
postgraduate programs that simply
learned
operates in partnership with major
universities like
purdue university mit
iit kanpur
um
so
if you are interested in those or if you
want to
look into those for your team members
i
recommend that you
reach out to me and i can send you
information
and
that is our webinar for today
so again
thank you so much
thank you
thank you to all of the audience members
for being here today
and
we hope to see you in the future and
we hope also to welcome you to the
simply learn learning community
bye-bye thank you
you